Avocados.
Americans love them.
For what other food
would you pay 15 dollars
to have someone bring it to your table
and mash it up in front of you?
There's probably a hipster
in Brooklyn right now
ordering a 15-dollar
avocado toast as we speak.
And that's on the cheap side.
Give me, like, 25 dollars.
I mean, that's insanity, honestly.
So I have a question.
Why would people pay seemingly
absurd prices for something so simple?
Marketing.
There was probably a time in the US
when you couldn't pay
people to eat avocados
and actually they were known
as “alligator pears”.
And then something changed.
In the 1990s,
there was a Super Bowl marketing campaign
where NFL players shared
their favorite guacamole recipes.
With the help of this, over time,
avocados went from a relative
obscurity in the US
to one of the most consumed fruits.
Now what’s interesting about this
is who was behind the campaign:
Californian avocado farmers.
They had a product,
they funded a highly visible
and successful marketing campaign,
put money in their pockets and ultimately
changed the way people eat.
So today I want to talk to you
about how marketing can be a catalyst
to improve the livelihoods of farmers,
but not in the US, in Africa.
And how the development community,
and by that, I mean NGOs, philanthropists
and international development agencies
can use marketing
to positively impact society,
the economy and the environment.
So I am South African and American,
I have lived and worked throughout Africa
with a professional focus
on food and agriculture.
And I've had the opportunity
to study lots of development programs
and even work on some myself.
And through that I have met farmers,
spoken to them,
and some of them have said,
"I have a product,
but I don't have a market
in which to sell it."
Or, "I have a market, but it's too small."
So I want to talk
about how to change that.
Now, just a reminder,
Africa is a continent, not a country.
And in sub-Saharan Africa,
agriculture makes up
a large part of the economy.
It makes up 20 percent of GDP,
about 60 percent of employment,
and many of the people
in agriculture are smallholders.
So they live on less
than two hectares of land
and have very small incomes that put them
at or below the poverty line.
For decades, the development community
has been trying to change this,
primarily with a supply side-focus
of working with farmers,
giving them access to seeds
and fertilizers,
showing them how to improve
their productivity
so that they could grow more,
have more to sell and eat
and ultimately increase their incomes,
which is the end goal.
Billions of dollars
have been spent on this.
And unfortunately, today,
many African farmers are still poor.
So why is that?
Well, farmers are part of the equation.
They supply food, but obviously we know
the other part of the equation is demand.
They need to have demand
for the goods that they're growing.
And it's true that the international
development community
is increasingly linking farmers to markets
so that they have places
to sell what they grow.
And that's good.
But they need to go a step further,
by proactively helping to shape
and grow markets
for goods grown by African farmers.
So in other words,
in addition to sending
seeds and fertilizer,
they need to send them
advertising geniuses.
So I'm going to share a couple of examples
of the type of impact marketing can have.
And I’m going to refer to the US a lot,
and that's because the US knows
how to do this really well.
Maybe a little too well, some might argue,
but that's not the topic
of the talk today.
So this is the slogan
of arguably one of the most iconic
ad campaigns of all time.
[got milk?]
Funded by American dairy farmers.
What's very interesting
about dairy in the US
is that companies don't leave it
up to individual businesses
to market their brands.
They actually work together
as an industry to promote milk drinking.
And they do this by, you know,
many companies contributing
to a common fund
that goes towards campaigns like this.
Now they have a little help
from government also.
How many of you went to school
and got milk on your tray?
In many instances,
that milk was subsidized.
Actually the National School Lunch Program
dates back to the 1940s,
and it's still ongoing today.
You go to school, you taste something,
it's at a good price,
you keep getting it, you like it,
maybe you start eating more of it.
You purchase at home, stock your fridge.
Does that sound anything
like product promotion and sampling?
Importantly, what this does is it creates
a whole category of consumers.
And it gives farmers a constant market
in which to sell what they grow,
and that's actually
really important, right?
You can't create a product
if you don't know that there's going to be
constant demand for it in the market.
Now this combination of industry marketing
plus government support
is quite powerful.
So powerful, in fact,
that the United States
has one of the highest rates
of consumption of dairy in the world:
653 pounds of dairy per person per year.
Try to imagine that.
That's a lot, right?
Now, this has actually been done
outside of the US, too.
In Kenya in the 1980s
under former president Moi,
there was a National School Milk Program,
dubbed Nyayo Milk,
and many Kenyan children went to school
and received packets of milk.
So it became a lot more
a part of the local diet.
And as they grew up,
they continued to consume it.
And today, Kenya has the highest rate
of consumption of dairy
in East Africa.
And it's got a much more
developed dairy industry
than its regional neighbors.
Now, both of those examples
are about marketing to domestic consumers.
But you're probably thinking,
"Well, what about, you know,
in countries where there's lower
purchasing power?"
You can use marketing to create
demand beyond borders as well.
If you've ever watched the Super Bowl,
and I never thought I'd talk so much
about the Super Bowl
because I kind of don't watch it.
But if you have ever watched
the Super Bowl
and you’ve heard this jingle
“Avocados from Mexico” --
and you kind of have to dance
when you sing it
because it’s just so catchy, honestly --
if you’ve heard that jingle,
then you've been marketed to
by the Mexican avocado industry.
Mexico exports 2.5 billion dollars worth
of avocados to the US every year.
That's obviously a lot of avocados
and a lot of money
going to Mexican avocado farmers.
And Kenya exports avocados, too,
but not that much.
So, you know, this is all
about how they can do that.
Now I've talked about milk, avocados,
but how many of you eat kale
or pomegranate or blueberries
because you've heard
that they're superfoods
packed full of antioxidants?
That's marketing.
So how do we take these examples
that I've talked about
and use them to improve
the livelihoods of farmers?
Three things.
First, development community.
Increase funding for demand
in addition to supply.
So in addition to funding
farmers to grow food,
donors need to fund world-class
marketing campaigns
that help farmers to sell food.
This should be done at local,
regional and international levels,
helping to promote the foods
grown by African farmers
and create trade within Africa,
but also outside African borders
with consumers in wealthier countries.
Second, governments.
Use your budgets to ensure
constant pools of demand.
As one of the largest
procurers for schools,
hospitals and other government facilities,
governments can use their budgets
to ensure that farmers
have constant marketplaces
in which to sell what they grow.
It can be done, as we've seen in Kenya.
And then third.
Farmers, work together to support
your common interests.
By jointly funding marketing campaigns
through industry bodies and cooperatives,
farmers can promote what they grow,
put money in their pockets
and ultimately change their lives,
which is the end goal.
Warning, big warning
in case anyone was losing me.
(Laughter)
Marketing can be a force for good,
but it can go too far,
especially if it's used to promote foods
that are full of fat, salt and sugar.
So what if, in addition
to everything I've said,
we not only use marketing to promote
foods grown by African farmers
but we use it to promote foods
that are more nutritious
and also better for the environment.
If we do that,
then we've got the triple play
of agriculture development:
increased farmer livelihoods,
more nutritious foods for consumers
and more sustainable agriculture.
So I'll give one last example using rice.
Rice is a staple crop,
and in many countries it is consumed
as a large part of diets.
However, white rice in particular
is low in nutrients,
it takes lots of water to grow,
and current techniques for growing rice
are contributing to a lot
of greenhouse gas emissions.
So what if we replace rice with millet?
Millet is a grain just like rice.
It is rich in fiber and antioxidants.
It has more calcium than milk per serving.
It takes 70 percent less water to grow,
and it is drought- and pest-resistant,
which is increasingly important
in today's world.
Sounds like a good alternative, right?
Well, there are lots
of other foods like this
that are both more nutritious
and more sustainable for the environment,
such as pumpkin leaves, sweet potatoes,
lentils, moringa and many others.
So we need to promote these foods,
develop tasty and affordable
recipes with them,
and importantly,
get celebrity chefs on board.
Because at the end of the day,
people need to want to eat these foods,
not be told they have to.
So I'll leave you with this.
Africa is still relatively early
in its development trajectory
versus other markets,
and it has the opportunity
to do things differently and better.
By using marketing
and a demand-led approach,
Africa can boost economic growth,
reduce incidences of diet-related diseases
and adapt to the challenges
of climate change.
Got millet?
(Laughter and applause)
Thank you.